françois durpaire spécialiste des états
unis bonsoir françois durpaire merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france donald
trump devrait prendre la parole ce soir
est ce que c'est un second essai en tout
cas après le flop de son premier meeting
on s'en souvient en oklahoma est ce que
donald trump va essayer de récupérer des
points ce soir
oui c'est important pour lui parce que
vous avez dit ce premier meeting a été
difficile il ya un enjeu c'est
l'inscription sur les listes électorales
vous savez qu avant de voter il faut
s'inscrire est là pour la première fois
depuis longtemps les républicains sont
en retard dans le inscriptions sur les
listes électorales dans un salon me
d'état et puis il ya le différentiel
dans les sondages qui devient très
important - 10 et dans quatre états
déterminant la flore et de michigan la
pennsylvanie et louise cantine et bien
donald trump est battu par son
adversaire joe biden qui lui ne fait pas
grand chose ce soir lui il sera en train
de répondre à des questions sur la
question raciale
une journaliste a pro américaine
d'événements qui est donc organisé ont
dix fois qu'il va du côté de cet
électorat afro américain joe biden
tandis que donne un train pluie et c'est
de creuser les divisions de l'amérique
c'est sa stratégie vous l'avais dit dans
le reportage
le discours notamment à au mont rushmore
hier était particulièrement édifiant oui
un discours où il critiquait notamment
le fait qu'on s'en prennent aux symboles
de l'amérique
7 ces manifestations du mouvement black
light ou matters à lui a créé du temps à
donald trump
oui alors ce qui a créé du tort à aden
un train tsé tsé tsé deux choses c'est
effectivement d'une part le kobe 19
cette crise sanitaire on lui reproche
aujourd'hui vous savez ils disent et
c'est le virus des chinois est
aujourd'hui les américains beaucoup en
tout cas dit c'est le virus de donald
trump
évidemment c'est pas lui qui a créé le
virus mais il lui reproche deux choses
la première c'est l'insuffisance sur le
plan technique il a pris des décisions
trop tardivement et peut-être pas les
bonnes et la deuxième c'est
l'insuffisance en matière j'avais dit
hier prêt
que d'humanisme un chef d'état ce n'est
pas un chef de gouvernement
on attend de lui également des mots pour
soigner la société pour accompagner les
malades les malades et leurs familles
des mots de compassion et de vent que
george w bush lors de trina en 2005
avait décroché dans les sondages au
moment de la catastrophe de katrina et
bien donald trump lui décroche dans les
sondages à ce moment là sauf que la
différence c'est que george w bush il
n'avait pas besoin d'être réélu c'était
son deuxième mandat donne un train pluie
a besoin d'être réélu alors il ya aussi
cette guerre des masques qui devient
politique puisque selon un sondage les
républicains emporte - alors que les
démocrates sont plutôt partisan de les
porter c'est devenu un symbole quasiment
de cette campagne
ça devrait être un simple outil
sanitaires et c'est devenu comme vous
l'avez dit un outil politique vous
portez un masque et bien ça veut dire
que vous êtes démocrate vous n'en
portait pas ça veut dire que vous ajouté
le président d'ailleurs ce fameux
discours hier au mont rushmore il y
avait qui me bat li guile foil qui est
la petite amie la compagne du chis cédé
2,2 d'un train qui est bien n'avait pas
de masque et vous savez que l es malade
à elle et à la loco buts 19 comme un
autre responsable de la campagne de dons
d'un train personnes quasiment de porter
de masque lors de ce discours
nouvelle provocation du camp donald
trump à ces démocrates qui eux disent il
y a vraiment une question de sanitaires
vous savez qu'il ya aujourd'hui vingt
mille contaminé de plus par jour aux
états unis
c'est pour vous donner une appréciation
à peu près cinq fois plus que dans
l'union européenne
pourtant compte 440 millions d'habitants
c'est à dire un tiers de plus que la
population américaine et du côté
américain bien on se dit là il ya
vraiment une manière de sous-estimer les
choses si donald trump se félicite de
ces bons résultats économiques et bien
ils devraient se dire que ces bons
résultats ne vont pas durer très
longtemps
ils sont en tout cas dépendant de
l'amélioration durable des résultats
sanitaire ne faut pas y avoir de
résultats économie
durable sans une stabilisation de la
situation sanitaire aux états unis comme
d'ailleurs c'est le cas en europe l'a
dit on l'a entendu 5 millions d'emplois
créés en juin c'est historique dit-il
sur les contaminations elles sont
effectivement extrêmement nombreux
donald trump dit finalement c'est parce
qu'on teste qu'on découvre qu'il ya des
malades finalement c'est parce que les
tests sont là et qu'on multiplie les les
tests quand on sait vous que c'est une
logique arithmétique implacable mais
qu'en fait de le dire de cette
manière-là sûr beaucoup d'américains
parce que il a l'air de prendre à la
légère ce qui se passe même si sur le
coup c'est juste si vous testez plus eh
bien vous avez plus évidemment de
chances de voir des malades mais il le
dit d'une manière assez particulière
quand vous l'entendez vous avez
l'impression que bien ils sous-estiment
la situation
ce qui est inquiétant pour lui c'est que
à moins 10 et derrière joe biden ça veut
dire que seul un seul président avait
réussi à rattraper ce retard c'étaient
truman en juillet 1948 alors vous allez
me dire est-ce que donald trump a déjà
perdu
pas forcément mais pour vous donner
quand même une indication hillary
clinton et bt à +41 et pas plus 10 par
rapport à donald trump donc certes
hillary clinton a perdu mais joe biden a
quand même des avantages par rapport à
hillary clinton lorsqu'on regarde deux
choses la première c'est le vote des
indépendants quand on regarde ces
fameuses indépendants et bien joe biden
est beaucoup moins polarisant qu'hillary
clinton ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
l'aiment et beaucoup moins de gens qui
le détestent
et puis il ya un deuxième chose c'est le
fameux vote des plus jeunes qui se
mobilisaient vous aviez cité blacklight
matin qui se sont mobilisés qui se sont
mobilisés aussi pour bernie sanders
il ne s'était pas reporter sur hillary
clinton mais là d'après toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion il semble que ce vote
étudiant ce vote des jeunes américains
et bien se reportent vers joe biden pour
une raison simple c'est que la stratégie
de polarisation le discours la
rhétorique belliciste de donald trump
stimule son électorat mais stimule
également ses opposants et en
particulier les jeunes
vous parlez d'une rhétorique belliciste
on va finir là-dessus donald trump s'est
qualifié lui-même de guerrier solitaire
ça a fait rire aussi aux états unis oui
alors évidemment ça fait rire le camp
qui n'aiment pas donald trump ça stimule
ses troupes
mais la question c'est effectivement un
la mobilisation en particulier la
mobilisation de ces fameux de ces
fameuses électeurs plus jeunes et puis
évidemment ces indépendants les
démocrates savent qu'ils voteront contre
denain trimpe les républicains pour
mais ce sont les indépendants dans
quelques états clés qui vont faire la
différence et si le vote à des lieux
aujourd'hui de notre homme serait
balayée par joe maiden le vote a lieu
aujourd'hui la lieu dans quatre mois ça
nous laisse encore le temps de
d'analyser cette situation et ça donne
encore un peu de temps la seule bonne
nouvelle pour donald trump c'est qu'il
reste encore quatre mois et on en
reparlera avec plaisir avec vous
françois durpaire merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur arte france